here's what would happen if we nuked  mars  there's a theory that if we nuked mars  it would become a habitable place for  humans but if this theory is incorrect  and we do in fact nuke mars it could go  horribly wrong  you know these things are capable of  destroying entire cities  the bombs we'd use on mars would be 1  000 times stronger than the ones used in  world war ii  if a bomb exploded right on the planet's  surface instead of up in the atmosphere  it would completely disfigure parts of  the surface and would cause even more  radiation it's also very likely that  instead of warming mars a bomb could  cause a nuclear winter  this could happen from all the dust and  particles in the atmosphere stirred up  by the nuclear explosions they'd almost  certainly block out the sun causing mars  to cool down even more so this probably  isn't the best idea because